[Musique]
on
au sabine le toullec enseignante à la
retraite
qu'est ce que je fais je m'occupe de
l'association bien sûr d'associations
absa nous avons créé cette association
il ya trente deux ans cette association
est née de la volonté d'une assistante
maternelle elle recevait des enfants
handicapés et elle ne savait pas quoi
faire avec eux et on a commencé à
travailler quand on a emmené ses jeunes
sur le terrain ici même d'ailleurs à
lambrakis va c'était comme si c'était le
siècle brasil qui étaient de sortie
les gens s'agglutiner autour pour
regarder et donc nous on a dit c'est pas
possible il faut absolument qu'on fasse
connaître les personnes handicapées
qu'on travaille avec eux pour changer ce
regard ce regard des gens qui n'avaient
jamais vu
et nous ça nous embêter et d'autant plus
que moi même j'ai un fils porteurs de
handicap et n'ont appris la valorisation
par le sport comment fait changer le
regard des personnes sur ces gens mais
comment aussi changer le regard de ces
personnes handicapées sur elle-même
parce que elle elle se trouvait vraiment
m'épuiser dévalorisé et en le sport
c'est un formidable vecteur se canto
russie ne serait ce qu'à mettre un
ballon dans un panier et que tout le
monde sait ou raouraoura on se sent
pousser des ailes c'est ce qui s'est
passé petit à petit petit à petit les
jeunes connu la réussite
connaissant la réussite et ont voulu
aller plus loin connaissant un sport ils
ont voulu faire d'autres sports d'autres
activités
clarisse qui est une athlète de chez
nous plusieurs fois championne en
athlétisme médaille d'un athlétisme
elle a été au marathon de new york est
allé aux états unis en irlande en grèce
on a rapporté des médailles des
médailles dos au but spécial olympique
faut avoir beaucoup de physique et
d'endurance et après il faut beaucoup
s'entraîner pour devenir champion après
mon but il venait d'aller plus encore
plus nos activités il ya de l'athlétisme
le vtt la natation la pétanque et la
zumba
toutes ces activités sont menées par un
éducateur spécialisé
nous aimons a créé l'association pour
les jeunes nous n'a créé l'association
pour les familles parce que souvent les
familles ont un sentiment de culpabilité
et donc on a dû quand même mon appui des
professionnels pour montrer à ces
familles que ya pas la culpabilité ça
peut arriver à n'importe qui d'avoir un
enfant porteur de handicap
[Musique]
je pense que c'est mon caractère parce
que quand on aime quelqu'un on aide
aussi soi même parce que moi aussi
j'étais dans le doute 1 quand j'ai eu un
enfant reproduit dans le doute 1 mais
j'ai la chance d'avoir de bons
professionnels qui m'ont bien accompagné
donc c'est pas ça maintenant que je peux
mettre ce que je j'ai reçu je prenais ça
aussi à vis des autres
le département comme on dit toujours
c'est du premier des premiers cris vous
dernier soupir
sans le département sans ses actions
qu'est-ce-qui ce conseil comme avant
finalement c'est sûr comme je dis
toujours rien n'est pensé mais
l'important c'est de le savoir
il envoie des améliorations si tu sais
c'est pas suffisant mais nous sommes
dans la bonne voie